欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,上一节课我们已经讲了
关于店铺分析的一个整体的框架
有平台维度的,有店铺维度的
那么这一节课我们就不讲平台维度了
我们来讲一下店铺维度的综合数据
如何去分析,如何去解决问题
那么这个范围会更加小一点点
首先我们来看一下
怎么样去看数据
才能够判断出趋势和方向
现在就请大家先记住一句话
就是数据只有对比才有价值
怎么样对比呢
第一个就是自己和自己对比
或者自己和同行对比
或者在不同时间段对比
本周跟上周对比
本月跟上月对比
按照这些维度去对比数据
才能够凸显出我们现在的数据的价值
那么第二个步骤就是实战的方法
也就是我们要利用好这个店铺综合数据表
然后每周每月去统计数据
按照下面的这些逻辑去分析找问题解决问题
那么这个表格我们已经发给大家了
那么大家用好这个表格完善数据就可以了
第三个步骤就是分析层级
我们一定要按照层级去分析
因为只有按照层级去分析
你才能够真正的找到问题,而且你的思路才能够更加的清晰
那么店铺的流量是由所有的产品的流量构成的,是吧
那么产品的流量是由什么构成的呢?是由自然流量和直通车的流量构成的
那么直通车的流量转化又是由产品词国家人群决定的
所以通过我们整个店铺的流量的层级
我们就能够快速的从左到右找到更加细的问题
通过这个维度找到问题之后我们才能够快速的解决问题
那么这个分析路径的话通常都是由大范围到小范围
先分析店铺的综合数据也就是我们现在这节课所讲的
先分析店铺的综合数据再拆解到产品分析对应的产品是吧
然后从产品再拆解到我们的直动车分析
是不是从大到小一步步去进行分析, 然后找到这些问题, 对这些问题进行具体的分析, 然后对应的解决
我们来看一下这个整体的一个流程, 我们主要依据的核心指标还是一模一样的, 曝光量, 点击量, 访客量, 询盘, TM, 还有订单量
这个层级, 不论你是在优化整个店铺, 还是在优化产品, 还是在优化自动车, 都遵从这一条主干线去分析和进行优化的
我们要记住,曝光量跟点击量之间有一个衡量的标准, 点击率, 点击量到访客量之间还有一个衡量的标准, 就是访客点击比, 访客量到询盘, TM之间有一个询盘转化率
那么循盘道订单, 有一个订单转化率, 这些指标, 我们只要把这个框架记住了之后, 你如果是开始不太理解, 或者是记不住的时候, 直接把它写在你的本质上面, 做店铺分析的时候, 直接对照着这个去做就可以了
比如说, 我们前半部分是关于流量的问题, 你看, 我这个蓝色的这个框里面, 代表的就是流量层级的问题
流量层级出现的问题,那么我们具体怎么样去提升我们店铺的流量问题呢?
首先第一个维度就是店铺层级的流量提升
想提升店铺流量层级,那么我们就要去提升我们店铺的质量流量
提升关键词的总量,有排名的一个位置
比如说关键词,有曝光,有点击,有循环的关键词,可能之前是100个
那么你提升到200个
500个, 上千个, 那么是不是你的店铺的总流量就会提升了
这些词本身排名可能在第三页
我想办法把它提升到第一页
是不是它的排名位置有所提升
排名位置提升了是不是能够获得流量的概率就会更大
增加整个店铺的总流量
第三个就是
如果你店铺里面的产品线比较少
那么你是不是可以考虑增加产品线
来拓宽我们整个店铺的流量范围
如果你只是做了一个普通定制品
那么我是不是有部分产品可以做现货的RTS的
我是不是也可以发一些来增加一下RTS的流量入口
因为RTS跟普通寻盘品
它们的流量入口在PC的首页或者APP的首页
它们的入口是不一样的
所看到的产品是不一样的
所以说, 你要通过赛道, 或者产品, 拓展, 都可以提升你整个店铺的总流量
另外一个就是, 资源上面, 我是不是可以有条件, 加大资源, 比如说, 问顶, 扑窗, 顶展, 等等这些, 我要去增加, 或者是说, 我提升它原来的, 一个效果
原来效果比较差, 那么我提升它的效能, 是不是也能够提升我整个店铺的流量
那么店铺流量的提升, 靠的是什么, 靠的是产品流量的提升, 那么这个是大的范围, 到继分到产品上面, 产品里面会有ABCDEFG, ABCDEFG等等这些类, 那么你就要去看哪些品类更加有增长空间, 以及哪些品类它的爆款啊, 实力优品的总量会更多, 这个是可以提升产品的流量的, 同时你要去持续的挖掘一些,
这些新的产品, 去提升流量, 因为有些, 比如说定向真品, 是吧, 也是平台的一些趋势产品, 那么你去提前去发, 那么这个产品可能就有容易获得流量
第三个就是真爆品和店铺爆款系列的打造, 也就是你这里面有很多爆品, 但是这些爆品可能就是没什么数据的, 那么你就要去证实一些真实的爆品, 也就是数据很好的那些爆品的维护和提升
它的整体的效果, 另外一个就是你的报款系列的打造, 比如说你有品类, A, B, C, D, F, G, 这么多产品品类, 你要确定打造某几个品类的报款系列, 才能够拓宽你整个产品的总流量, 因为产品是由多个品类构成的嘛, 如果你只是做了A品类的爆品, 那么其他的都没有爆品, 那么相当于它覆盖的人群, 或者是说它覆盖的关键词本身就比较有局限性,
所以你需要通过打造爆款系列, 也就是打造多个品类的爆品, 才能够快速的提升你这个产品的流量
最后面一个也就是刚才讲的那个就是增加多品类获取循环
因为你有些店铺他做ABCDEFG这么多品类
那么他获得循环的品类可能就是A品类而已
其他品类基本都没什么循环
所以你要提升其他品类的一个循环增长
就能够提升你的产品流量
那么从产品流量再细分的话就是转化是吧
比如说这些都是流量的维度
你流量有了到这个成绩了
那么你的循盘必须要有增长是吧
如果没有循盘那么我们所有的工作都是白忙了嘛
细分到更细的一个核心的指标去优化
比如说转化率的提升
转化率的提升靠什么
一个是关键值是否精准
这个决定着你是否能够得到转化
第二个就是目标市场是否精准
决定着你的寻盘的质量是不是更好
人群是否精准也是决定着你的寻盘的质量是不是比较好
那么质量就会决定着你订单是否容易成交
所以这里的每一个维度它对应要优化或者是调整的内容是不一样的
最后就是产品款式, 价格, NOQ, 运费是否合理
这些都会直接影响到你的这个订单是否容易成交
所以我们一定要按照这个层级从左到右,从大到小的范围去进行一个分析
这里我们讲的主要是一些整体的一个分析思路
因为具体的操作,我想如果你把我前面的内容都学了
那么对于这些维度你要去看数据或者是判断都能够在后台找得到具体的数据
这里我主要是讲一些更加实用的思路给你, 让你以后能够更加灵活的去应用
那么这节课我们就主要是讲关于店铺综合数据的一个分析的一个整体的框架跟一些具体细分维度的这些方法
如果你本来是没有什么框架或者是说你去分析的时候总是没有什么思路的话
我建议你可以对照着这个流程去多操作几遍
很快你就能够有一定的思路
也能够帮你梳理一下你原来的那些知识点
让你在原始的基础上再进一步的提升
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们继续讲更加细分的维度